bonsoir et bienvenue dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir une journaliste engagée
l'un des visages de la génération climat
Salomé saké et notre grand témoin ce
soir bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette
émission que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous y avez été chroniqueuse
soit jeune et tais-toi c'est votre
premier livre chez Payot manifeste
contre le baching antigène on a du temps
on va en parler dans la deuxième partie
mais on commence bien sûr ce soir avec
les retraites 10e journée d'action
malgré de fortes tensions dans les
cortèges la flambée de violence redoutée
n'a pas eu lieu dans le pays du moins à
7h03 fait à retenir ce soir la médiation
proposée par l'Inter syndical et refusé
par le gouvernement et Gérald Darmanin
et bien sonne la charge contre la gauche
qu'il accuse d'être Antipolis on en
parle dans notre grand débat dans un
instant avec nos invités et puis à 20h15
les parties pris de nos affranchis et
puis Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée vous me suivez
Salomé Sakho voilà pour le menu c'est
parti
[Musique]
inflexible malgré cette nouvelle journée
d'action encore assez suivie on va voir
les chiffres dans un instant suivi
notamment par les jeunes le mouvement
émaillé de tension en fin de cortège on
va y revenir le gouvernement qui dit non
au syndicat ni médiation ni suspension
de la réforme tenir et durcir le ton
notamment contre la gauche est-ce que ça
peut suffire bonsoir Mathieu Lefèvre et
merci d'être là vous êtes députés
renaissance du Val-de-Marne bonsoir
Marie-Christine Daloz ravi de vous
accueillir député les républicains du
Jura je précise que vous n'avez pas voté
la censure du gouvernement bonsoir
marie-charlotte-garin bonsoir bienvenue
dans cette émission députée
europécologie les Verts du Rhône enfin
bonsoir Michel Boga bienvenue vous êtes
le monsieur retraite de Force Ouvrière
secrétaire confédérale de FO vous
quittez le cortège à l'instant pour
rejoindre ce plateau Salomé saké
évidemment votre regard sur ce mouvement
nous intéresse notamment sur la
mobilisation au très forte de la
jeunesse on va y revenir avec un
reportage un peu plus tard mais d'abord
l'ampleur du mouvement les chiffres et
les images le fil de la journée en deux
secondes le chrono de Blacko pour
démarrer
bonsoir Stéphane blackovski bonsoir
Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous 450000 à
Paris selon la CGT
93000 sur la police et 700 000 dans
toute la France selon mais le ministère
de l'Intérieur exactement les chiffres
de la dixième journée de mobilisation
alors pour résumer on va dire que même
la CGT reconnaît que le nombre de
manifestants est en baisse par rapport à
la semaine dernière bon faut pas en
déduire qu'il y a un essoufflement pour
autant du mouvement regardez c'est déjà
arrivé sur les mobilisations précédentes
que il y a une baisse de mobilisation et
hop qu'elle reparte de plus belle lors
du rassemblement suivant ça s'est
produit plusieurs fois donc on ne peut
pas dire que il y a une démobilisation
avec un mouvement régulier dans ce
sens-là ce matin c'est pas du tout la
question de la mobilisation qui
préoccupait la presse regardez ce qui
faisait la UNE notamment de la presse
régionale Lille Lyon Nantes on
s'inquiétait surtout des risques de
débordement violent il y en a eu la
semaine dernière ce week-end il y a eu
un redoublement de violence au Méga
bassines donc c'était vraiment
l'inquiétude et bon c'est vrai que c'est
quand même dommage notamment pour
l'instant médical 8 mobilisations qui se
déroule quasiment 100 heures des records
historiques de manifestants et
aujourd'hui ben voilà on ne parle que
des risques de violence alors pour
résumer un petit peu graphiquement cette
situation où est-ce que je fais comme
graphique vous allez me dire ça c'est
1000 manifestants pour chaque point
orange donc à Paris la préfecture
prévoyait 100000 manifestants quelle est
la place des casseurs là dessus 1000
donc voilà c'est ils sont ils
représentent exactement ça les casseurs
et pourtant tout se focalise autour de
cette question des casseurs on a
mobilisé 15000 policiers un record donc
il s'agirait de faire baisser un petit
peu l'attention de trouver la voie de
l'apaisement donc l'insert syndicale
prend l'initiative ce matin et dit on a
qu'à mettre de côté la question des 64
ans et puis discuter de ce dont le
président voulait parler c'est à dire la
fin des carrières longues la pénibilité
voilà avancer sur ces sujets liés au
travail mais on reparlera plus tard
éventuellement évidemment des 64 ans
alors réponse du gouvernement le
problème c'est qu'ils ont un totem au
gouvernement vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un totem c'est sinon la colère des
dieux s'abat sur vous donc les 64 ans
c'est le totem du gouvernement on veut
bien discuter sans parler de façon de 4
ans sans médiateur et puis pas tout de
suite on écoute le porte-parole du
gouvernement d'abord
on n'a pas forcément besoin de médiation
pour se parler on peut se parler
directement le président de la
République il a dit il est prêt à
recevoir l'intersydical dès lors parce
que nous respectons nos institutions que
le Conseil constitutionnel ce sera
prononcé sur la conformité de notre
texte de loi alors il faut se mettre à
la place de Laurent Berger vous savez
que c'est toujours vexant quand vous
tendez à la main à quelqu'un comme ça et
puis il refuse de l'apprendre c'est
arrivé à Nicolas Sarkozy au sein de
l'agriculture il avait réagi en disant
casse-toi pauvre con heureusement
Laurent Berger est beaucoup plus modéré
on l'écoute
ça va commencer à suffire les fins de
non-recevoir à la discussion au dialogue
il va falloir s'interroger sur qui ne
veut pas le dialogue il suffit pas de
dire partout on veut le dialogue mais on
veut pas discuter par exemple des
retraites c'est pas possible regardez ce
qui se passe derrière nous comment vous
voulez qu'on aille discuter si on peut
pas parler des retraites dans cette
période c'est là qu'on voit que Laurent
Berger est un homme modéré combien
d'autres aurait dit ça commence à bien
faire non il dit ça va commencer à
suffire donc voilà quelqu'un de modéré
qui tend la main peut-être qu'il
faudrait saisir cette main dans la
majorité tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord mais côté modem oui on dit
quand même oui il faudrait peut-être la
prendre cette main on écoute Philippe
Vigier
le dialogue social on ne peut pas le
laisser de côté dans ce pays
et nous nous disons avec beaucoup de
détermination
notamment avec le geste qui a été
accompli encore ce matin par Laurent
Berger
demandant que on puisse remettre tout le
monde autour de la table et nous
l'appelons de nos vœux dans les
meilleurs délais
alors je vous laisse débattre juste je
vous rappelle qu'en 2010 pour imposer sa
réforme des retraites Nicolas Sarkozy
avait affronté 14 journées de
mobilisation est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
compte battre ce record je ne sais pas
ah très bien on la prend 14 peut-être
que c'est l'objectif du gouvernement une
fois n'est pas coutume je vais commencer
avec vous Michel beaugazon on va venir
sur la main tendue de Laurent Berger la
médiation mais déjà sur le bilan que
vous tirez de cette dixième journée
d'action 450 000 apparis selon la CGT
c'était 800000 quand même jeudi dernier
93.000 selon la police dans la dans la
capitale pas d'essoufflement non il y a
pas il y a pas des soufflement
ça a été rappelé en fait en fonction des
journées d'action il y a plus ou moins
de personnes il y a plus ou moins de de
grévistes aujourd'hui c'est encore une
très très forte mobilisation nos calculs
font plus de 2 millions 2 millions 250
000 à peu près manifestants dans toute
la France et encore une très très forte
mobilisation et compris dans les grèves
parce qu'on sait que ça commence à
coûter cher avec un peu moins de
grévistes mais le principe de la
manifestation c'est c'est pas forcément
c'est pas forcément la grève aujourd'hui
ce qu'on veut faire entendre au
gouvernement c'est que la majorité des
Français 94% des salariés et une grande
majorité de Français plus de 70 % sont
contre cette réforme c'est pas très
compliqué à entendre des manifesteurs
des manifestations qui n'ont jamais été
aussi nombreuses de tout temps
le 6 avril prochain à nouveau vous
appelez tous unis à défiler jeudi
prochain jeudi prochain encore une fois
jusqu'à que le Président de la
République parce que c'est quand même un
peu lui qui ferme la porte je rappelle
que quand on parle de ma tendu du
président de la République la dernière
fois qu'on lui a tendu la main on lui
écrivant recevez nous il nous a dit il
n'y a rien à voir elle est allé voir
ailleurs et et nous continuons
par le chef de l'État
et donc et mais il mais on est on
atteint syndicale aujourd'hui enfin
c'est pas une question de Force Ouvrière
ou de CFDT ou de CGT nous sommes en
inter syndicale la terre syndicale et
historiquement la plus longue qu'on est
connue aussi et donc ce qu'ils font
entendre à nouveau syndicat c'est vrai
vous confirmez on verra mais en
attendant l'interseical tient ce qui
avait fait des paris sur scan tiennent
pas si longtemps et bien elle tiendra je
sais pas si Emmanuel Macron feu aura le
record de 15 manifestations contre lui
plutôt 14 à Nicolas Sarkozy en tout cas
ce qu'on sait c'est que la politique qui
est menée aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
très différente qu'à l'époque de Nicolas
Sarkozy l'Inter syndical va tenir et
vous aussi c'est ça l'idée au risque
d'un dérapage au risque d'un drame que
tout le monde redoute vous savez on n'a
pas de totem j'entendais parler de totem
le seul totem qu'on est c'est
l'équilibre de notre système de retraite
parce qu'on ne veut pas que dans 10 ans
ou dans 15 ans on vienne nous dire mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait sous le
second quinquennat Macron en tel point
qu'on est aujourd'hui incapable de
verser les pensions de gens qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie je me réjouis
d'abord qu'aujourd'hui manifestement il
y a eu moins de violence à l'occasion de
se manifestations je pense qu'on peut
tous
tension je précise en ce moment même à
la place de la Nation à Paris ne parlons
pas trop vite en effet mais ce qu'il
faut bien dire c'est que la main du
Gouvernement et la majorité elle a
toujours été tendu aux organisations
syndicales la porte elle a toujours été
ouverte en revanche sur les 64 ans les
64 ans on en veut pas à aucun prix mais
si on n'a pas cette mesure d'âge d'abord
on n'aura pas les effets escomptés en
matière d'emploi des seniors comme nous
en sommes instruits par les réformes
précédentes et deuxièmement ça voudrait
dire qu'il faudrait accélérer très
singulièrement la réforme Touran pour
passer demain à 45 années de cotisation
ce serait je crois profondément juste
pour les gens qui ont commencé à
travailler tardivement et également pour
les personnes qui ont des carrières
hachées donc on voit bien qu'il n'y a
pas de plan B il n'y a pas d'alternative
à ce projet de réforme si ce n'est
peut-être de ça
c'est pas du tout ce que disent les
syndicats et notamment Laurent Berger on
va pas refaire le match du fond de la
réforme parce que je crois qu'on est
dans un face à face assez dur
aujourd'hui Marie-Charlotte Garin vous
étiez dans le corps le cortège
aujourd'hui on est quand même sur une
ligne de crête on voit bien maintenant
qu'il y a un face à face entre la police
et les casseurs vous vous avez le
sentiment que continuer le mouvement ses
responsable je crois que ça a été très
bien rappelé tout à l'heure c'est que
les casseurs se représentent une
minorité que l'immense majorité des
manifestations partout en France passent
de manière très pacifique voire même de
manière joyeuse donc ça il faut quand
même le souligner aujourd'hui c'est la
question de l'apaisement en fait qui est
posée et dans l'état actuel on a un
gouvernement qui gouverne un peu
finalement seul contre tous dans le
mépris aussi des corps intermédiaires
qui tentent des mains et qui se voient
essuyer des refus et c'est là où il y a
un problème pourquoi s'entêter alors que
on a une intercendicale inédite on a des
mobilisations inédites on a des gens
pour qui ça coûte très très cher
aujourd'hui de faire grève enfin ça je
tiendrai rappeler quoi parce que c'est
pas neutre de faire grève dans un
contexte où l'inflation est ce qu'elle
est ça a un coût et malgré ce coup alors
que le gouvernement avait fait le pari
de l'anesthésie des Français et des
Françaises ils sont en rendez-vous et
ils se mobilisent pour la 10ème journée
aujourd'hui alors on va rester un peu
sur la manifestation et aller voir ce
qui se passe dans les cortèges notamment
dans la jeunesse Marie-Christine Daloz
pour les républicains qui s'entêtent
aujourd'hui qui sans tête
je sais pas si on peut parler
d'entêtement ou pas d'endettement moi
j'entends que la réforme elle a été
adoptée malgré les conditions que l'on
connaît il y a une adoption de la
réforme aujourd'hui ce texte il est
c'est au Conseil constitutionnel de se
proposer de se prononcer je crois qu'il
faut respecter nos institutions le
Conseil constitutionnel va dire si le
texte est conforme ou non à notre juge
de paix final pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est la procédure actuelle on est dans
cette procédure-là premièrement
deuxièmement moi j'entends effectivement
une main tendue très bien mais une main
tendue sous condition c'est à dire on
vient mais on exclut l'article 7 or sur
les 64 ans de la réforme l'article 7
c'est effectivement les 64 ans
le texte de la réforme telle qu'il a été
transmis au Conseil constitutionnel il
intègre bien l'article 7 et je rappelle
qu'à la base à l'origine c'était 65 dans
le projet de réforme du gouvernement on
est passé de 64 à 65 à 64 ans je
n'entends pas souvent dire ce élément-là
mais il y a eu une année de gagner alors
vous me direz il y a toujours deux ans
de plus mais tout le monde rêverait de
partir à la retraite à 55 ans de pouvoir
financer mais est-ce qu'on la vraie
question à se poser aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on veut préserver et garder un
système par répartition
d'entendre un député Renaissance vous
seriez prêt vous à participer à cette
élargissement c'est la mission du de la
première ministre non moi je n'ai pas
été élu sur le programme d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est très clair je ne renierai
jamais mes origines politiques et ma
constance politique qui aurait publié au
gouvernement non non voilà exactement
c'est non par contre que sur des textes
aussi comment dire fort et important
pour l'avenir de notre pays on puisse
effectivement négocier discuter et se
dire qu'en responsabilité on va le voter
c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait sur la
réforme des retraites on va parler de
cette main tendue je sens que vous avez
vraiment envie de savoir si il faut la
saisir cette médiation ou pas mais
restons je vous l'avais dit dans le
cortège 400 000 jeunes mobilisés dans
toute la France ce sont les chiffres de
l'UNEF c'est très marquant de voir le
nombre de l'Université de lycée des
dizaines bloquées dans le pays Clément
pervaud et Arnaud Paillard ont rencontré
ces jeunes reportages
[Musique]
c'est une tendance très significative à
Paris aujourd'hui il pesait près d'un
tiers des manifestants
les jeunes étudiants lycéens et sont
devenus incontournables dans les
cortèges les fax sont bloquées les
lycées sont bloqués j'ai même vu des
collèges qui étaient bloqués donc là
ouais la jeunesse est mobilisée la
jeunesse c'est dans la rue pour dire non
au gouvernement pour dire NON la réforme
des retraites mais aussi pour dire non à
l'écrasement de la démocratie qu'on aura
à me subir
et à révolution permanente et dans les
vagues depuis quelques semaines on
essaye de construire en fait
désormais général massives en fait
l'impression que que depuis le 49-3 en
fait il y a une vraie colère en fait qui
s'exprime et un peu exceptionnel il y a
toutes les facs qui étaient un peu
considérés comme apolitique qui s'engage
par exemple avec le blocus de Dauphine
non je suis lycéen tu Val d'Oise la
banlieue et je vais venir m'exprimer au
nom de jupe pour ceux qui le peuvent pas
c'est le sujet qui fait le plus parler
en ce moment comme partout en France je
pense on a quand même un lycée qui est
plutôt mobilisé donc c'est c'est cool ça
fait plaisir à voir
rêve général ça va péter anticapitaliste
anti fasciste voilà les slogans scandés
dans les mégaphones de cette jeunesse
mobilisée une jeunesse qui assume une
radicalité plus forte que les cortèges
syndicaux
[Musique]
isoler de la personne nickel et faire
une grève générale puisse se mettre en
place pour en fait à un mouvement qui
soit dur et qu'il soit ferme et qui en
fait mettent dava le la réforme et le
gouvernement aujourd'hui au bout d'un
moment le gouvernement il coûte pas
c'est ce qu'on a envie c'est se faire
entendre donc j'imagine qu'au bout d'un
moment oui ça peut durcir ça peut
devenir de plus en plus violent
potentiellement des deux côtés
moi je pense que si le gouvernement ne
veut pas entendre pacifiquement ça va
commencer à devenir violent et manifeste
on est calme et tout mais en fait il y a
un moment où
bah c'est la seule manière de se faire
entendre en fait c'est horrible d'en
arriver là mais voilà alors que les
chiffres de participation aux manifs
sont en baisse par rapport à la semaine
dernière la mobilisation des jeunes ne
faiblit pas elle représente un espoir
pour le mouvement de survivre dans la
durée
voilà Salomé saké cette fois-ci elle se
tait pas la jeunesse elle se fait
entendre elle veut se faire entendre et
ça dépasse on voit le cadre des
retraites comment vous comprenez ce qui
se passe et quand on dit grève générale
ça va péter Macron démission ses
responsable ou pas pour vous je pense
qu'il y a vraiment eu un basculement qui
s'est opéré à partir de l'utilisation du
49-3 qui a été interprétée par beaucoup
de jeunes comme un déni de démocratie et
on le voit et ça a été montré par des
sociologues comme Camille Pony par
exemple les jeunes ont une sensibilité
et une aspiration à la démocratie et
alors évidemment il y a le contenu de la
réforme des retraites les jeunes ont des
proches aussi qui font peut-être bientôt
partir à la retraite ils ont leurs
parents ils ont leur entourage c'est
dans presque 50 ans c'est aussi pour
leur entourage ils sont évidemment
sensibles au contenu de cette réforme
mais là où il y a vraiment eu ce
basculant c'est avec le 49-3 et ils le
disent dans votre dans votre reportage
c'est ces jeunes qui ont l'impression de
ne pas être écoutés d'être méprisées par
le gouvernement ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai vraiment retrouvé dans les
différentes interviews que j'ai pu faire
avec beaucoup de jeunes qui ont
l'impression justement sacrifie leur
futur et non pas du tout la sensation
que cette réforme des retraites
permettrait de préserver leur futur au
contraire notamment par l'inaction
climatique je rappelle que l'État a été
condamné deux fois pour une action
climatique le conseil pour climat juste
insuffisantes non mais on le voit dans
les cortèges le climat est en train de
faire son entrée dans les revendications
et donc effectivement il y a une très
grosse colère
dans la jeunesse française qui pourra
peut-être permettre de faire perdurer ce
mouvement de contestation de la réforme
vous connaissez la formule la jeunesse
c'est comme le dentifrice c'est facile
de la faire sortir c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à faire entrer qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire comment vous allez
faire mais d'abord je crois qu'il faut
dire assez jeune que cette réforme c'est
pour eux que nous la faisons ils
s'apprête à rentrer dans la vie active
on entend peu ce discours mais s'apprête
à rentrer dans la vie active si demain
ils veulent avoir une pension à la
hauteur de tout ce qui pourront cotiser
tout au long de leur vie c'est grâce à
cette réforme et je vais vous dire
peut-être grâce à d'autres réformes que
d'autres gouvernements responsables
feront dans les années à venir et par
ailleurs on est dans le dialogue de
sourd aucun des jeunes de début
d'après-midi dans les cortèges ne vous
entend là dessus
et par ailleurs un autre message moi
pendant des années ma génération m'a dit
avoir un emploi c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile c'était le
chômage de masse aujourd'hui on est
quasiment au plein emploi c'est une
promesse qu'aucun autre gouvernement
n'est pas venu à tenir cette promesse là
on la tient aussi pour la jeunesse on a
parce que vraiment ce qu'on retrouve
chez les jeunes c'est c'est de dire ok
on a peut-être des emplois mais ils sont
extrêmement précaires le marché du
travail est flexibilisé on n'arrive pas
à attendre les emplois qu'on désire on
est sur des périodes de plus en plus
longues avec des emplois de plus en plus
difficiles et donc peut-être qu'il y a
effectivement un accès à des emplois
mais des emplois qui ne sont pas ceux
auxquels aspire les jeunes qui sont tout
simplement même un tenables parfois
physiquement et psychologiquement avoir
la majeure partie des emplois sont des
emplois en CDI ça n'est pas ce ne sont
pas que des emplois précaires et par
ailleurs rendez-vous compte votre que
vaut-il mieux être au chômage se
trouvait dans des situations de
précarité jusqu'à ses 25 26 ans avant
que de pouvoir accéder au RSA est-ce que
c'est cela on préfère pour notre
jeunesse moi je préfère que les jeunes
ils aient une expérience
plutôt que la solution proposée par
l'extrême gauche qui est finalement une
allocation universelle pour tous les
jeunes voilà ce que nous propose les
autres options politiques
Marie-Charlotte gain l'élu écologiste
que vous êtes dehors d'extrême gauche
mais c'est important parce que en gros
les examens du Bac ça y est c'est fait
il y a rien jusqu'en juin vous leur
dites continuez jusqu'en juin mais moi
je dis continuer jusqu'à ce que vous
ayez le sentiment d'être entendu en fait
c'est aussi simple que ça et dire que
c'est une réforme qui est pour les
jeunes en fait ça n'est pas juste parce
qu'on nous propose une réforme qui a un
rapport au travail qui est complètement
à côté de la plaque quand on voit les
aspirations des jeunes qui arrivent sur
le marché du travail en fait les
aspirations aujourd'hui c'est de
travailler moins et c'est de travailler
mieux et c'est absolument en fait cette
réforme elle va rebours du sens de
l'histoire et vraiment moi ce que
j'entends j'intervenais hier dans un
lycée j'ai des jeunes qui me disaient
mais madame avec le 49-3 on a un
problème de démocratie dans le pays non
alors justement
le mouvement il est en train de se
décaler sur la question démocratique
notamment avec la Genèse depuis le 49-3
vous leur dites quoi faut rester sur les
retraites la question sociale ou hop on
y va tous maintenant c'est le régime
qu'il faut questionner la question alors
la question principale là où appelle
l'intersielle c'est bien la question des
retraites ensuite effectivement le fait
d'avoir utilisé le 49-3 provoque une
certaine illusivité morale et
démocratique parce que il y a pas eu de
vote à l'Assemblée nationale c'est ça
qu'il faut constater parce que pourquoi
il y a pas eu de vote à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons rencontré tous les
groupes parlementaires on savait nous
qui n'aurait pas de majorité pourquoi
l'intersyndicale demandait le vote à
l'Assemblée nationale parce que le
gouvernement aurait été battu un article
voilà notamment c'est bien là et donc il
a choisi le 49-3 il a choisi une autre
voie qui sont tout à fait légales qui
sont constitutionnels
avec vous mais nous en quelque sorte
pour l'Inter syndical en tout cas pour
force ouverte on se dit que le 49-3
c'est déjà une victoire de
l'intersyndicale parce que le gouverne
on a repoussé le gouvernement dans ces
retranchements voilà c'est que il a les
perdre et aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit à la
jeunesse
vous l'avez rappelé les examens sont
passés voilà parce que j'étais un peu en
retrait quand même depuis le début du
mouvement ils sont massivement ça fait
deux ça fait que deux manifestations on
les voit massivement et donc pour vous
dire effectivement votre avenir ce n'est
pas de travailler plus longtemps parce
que
la différence c'est la différence de
lecteur je suis membre du conseil de
l'orientation des retraites je suis
membre du conseil de l'orientation de
l'emploi
des jeunes ça a été rappelé ce qu’on
leur propose aujourd'hui c'est la
précarité et les petits boulots moi j'ai
les enfants et bien ils ont fait des
études et ce qu'on leur a proposé c'est
d'abord des CDD avant de leur proposer
un CDI et ça ça c'est une honte avant
surtout ils ont pas on l'a surtout pas
proposé aux entreprises on a surtout pas
mis dans le texte comment contraindre
les entreprises à conserver les salariés
de plus de 50 ans parce qu'il est là le
problème il est un problème en plus
l'article aujourd'hui
27 40 ans voilà et ça suffit pas pour
avoir les 25 meilleures années déjà
aujourd'hui et donc l'ensemble des
salariés dans la précarité je trouve que
tout cela est un peu excessif je vais
jouer les pondérés premièrement on nous
dit les examens sont passés oui les deux
épreuves du bac nouvelle version sont
passées mais faut pas oublier que les
ceux qui passent leur baccalauréat cette
année les lycéens qui sont en terminale
vont avoir des épreuves de contrôle
continu et qu'il y aura d'autres
épreuves au mois de juin et le contrôle
continu il va être sur des notes
j'espère que les cours pourront avoir
lieu parce qu'on va pas sacrifier le bac
de tous nos lycéens de cette année de
toutes les terminales simplement parce
que il y a des jeunes qui bloquent et je
voudrais juste rappeler que tout le
monde parle de la mobilisation des
jeunes très bien mais elle a été
largement instrumentalisée mais
largement instrumentalisé monsieur je me
rappelle dans l'hémicycle monsieur
Boyard qui appelait à la mobilisation de
tous les jours
mais c'était vraiment impressionnant la
façon dont c'était traité dans
l'hémicycle il y avait pas un député de
la France insoumise qui n'appelait pas
les jeunes à se mobiliser et pour
terminer et pour terminer quand on nous
parle de déni de démocratie moi je suis
j'entends ce terme-là de la rue mais il
a été employé aussi par Charles de
Courson à la tribune de l'Assemblée
est-ce que les 17000 amendements de la
France insoumise n'était pas un déni de
démocratie pour qu'on nous n'arriv ions
pas une transition tout trouver la
France insoumise cible très clairement
maintenant du gouvernement de la
majorité Renaissance et je l'entends
également du côté d'une partie des
républicains Gérald Darmanin cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
confonde casseurs et policiers que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on n'est
pas un mot dans une question d'actualité
pour penser à tous ces policiers ces
gendarmes qui sont blessés que s'est-il
passé à gauche quand on a pas un mot
quand on attaque des commissariats des
tribunaux des préfectures des
permanences de parlementaires que
s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
confond manifestation interdite et
manifestation autorisées que s'est-il
passé à gauche pour qu'on ne respecte
plus l'uniforme de la République que
s'est-il passé à gauche madame la
députée pour qu'on oublie à ce point
Clémenceau Chevènement Cazeneuve Valls
Mitterrand Badinter
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
aisse des policiers que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour faire alliance avec Monsieur
Mélenchon qui les insultent qui les
vomit et qui finalement fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche
Marie-Charlotte Garin finalement la nuit
pêche Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait honte à
vos électeurs je rappelle que la
question est posée par votre groupe les
écologistes j'ai envie de répondre
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans ce
gouvernement pour qu'on fragilise à ce
point la parole politique et qu'on monte
à répétition sur ce texte la colère elle
vient de là aussi il y a une mensonge de
1200 euros c'est toutes les questions
qu'on a posé dans les cycle auxquelles
on n'a pas eu de réponse le ministre
d'armanin il a menti à nouveau je prends
l'exemple de Sainte-Souline sur qui
aurait pas eu d'armes de guerre qui
aurait été utilisées etc il y a tous les
observateurs neutres qui
qui contredisent la parole du
gouvernement et je le dis avec un peu de
gravité parce que moi ça me met
profondément en colère en tant que jeune
élu et en tant que jeune tout court
parce qu'ils sont en train de créer
justement une génération qui va
nourrir une forme de défiance
extrêmement forte envers nos
institutions qui ne va plus vouloir
aller voter qui va se dire pourquoi je
vais aller voter parce que ça sert à
rien et quand demain les extrêmes se
retrouveront aux portes pour voir ce
sont eux les responsables uniquement
quand vous voyez des élus écharpe
tricolores en bandoulière à
sainte-solines dans les Deux-Sèvres
manifestation interdite dont on sait
très bien que il y a un très très haut
risque de débordement la radicalisation
écologique ça existe depuis longtemps
c'est leur place vraiment
on ne peut pas enlever à des personnes
qui ont porté des combats avant de
porter les charpes de continuer à les
porter après et la présence des élus
elle a permis de sécuriser des personnes
qui étaient blessées ce week-end on a
des témoignages qui sont très marquants
et qui sont très forts d'un cordon qui a
été fait par les élus pour éviter
justement que des personnes qui étaient
blessées et donc pronostic vital a été
engagé par la suite qu'elle ne soit pas
plus exposée aux violences
Garin en réalité quand une élue de la
République va dans une manifestation
interdite c'est une brèche dans l'État
de droit vous n'avez pas eu un mot pour
condamner ces violences vous n'avez pas
eu un mot pour ces policiers attaquer à
coups de hache à coups de boules de
pétanque c'était reste qui ont reçu des
pavés à la tête dans quel monde
vivons-nous la France insoumise et
laupes
un mot en réalité pour conforter notre
démocratie et dans le fond
l'histérisation du débat politique dont
vous vous rendez coupable elle finit
toujours par déborder dans une violence
verbale et dans une violence physique
dans la rue je crois qu'il faut la
condamner la condamner extrêmement
fermement et je regrette que vous en
soyez ce soir encore incapable il nous
reste moins de 5 minutes je voudrais
qu'on parle de cette main tendue un mot
là-dessus Salomé saké rapidement oui
simplement moi je voudrais dire que le
gouvernement n'a pas eu un mot pour les
personnes qui ont été victimes de
violences policières et ça c'est ce que
je vous montre aussi dans mon livre
effectivement alors il y a une enquête
de l'IGPN qui était ouverte
mais en revanche on nous reprendrons
jamais notre compte le terme de violence
policière de violence policière
systémique madame il y a en effet
parfois des comportements tout à fait
déviants qui sont évidemment scrutés et
qui font l'objet dans lequel judiciaire
et administrative mais parler de
violence policière c'est José nos
propres sur des femmes et des hommes qui
servent la République toute la journée
en tout cas c'est violence sont assez
nombreuses pour qu'on le retrouve dans
les statistiques pour qu'on le retrouve
dans les études sociologiques que encore
une fois j'ai essayé de montrer et de
citer dans ce livre qui crée une rupture
avec le rat des sanctions quand il y a
eu des dérapages
le vrai constat qu'on est en train de
faire aujourd'hui et c'est dramatique
moi j'ai des petits enfants et quand mes
enfants sont grands donc j'ai des petits
enfants aujourd'hui je n'ai pas envie de
les voir vivre dans un monde où on a
banalisé la violence parce que c'est ça
le vrai sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
cautionne toute la violence possible et
imaginables c'est venu et c'est vrai que
ça a été rappelé un petit peu
aujourd'hui j'en ai entendu parler
Notre-Dame-des-Landes on est parti en
terme de violence de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et depuis on
déborde à chaque fois qu'il y a des
manifestations avec des scènes de
violence des scènes de guerre vous savez
jeudi soir à Paris c'était quoi
mais la réalité madame c'est que si vous
aussi vous vous ne condamnez pas si
violence quel qu'elle soit toutes les
violences sont les dégradations
c'est le cœur de cette question des
retraites sur la médiation Michel bogaz
expliquez-nous précisément ce que
propose l'Inter syndicale au
gouvernement vous voulez suspendre la
réforme des retraites pour nommer un ou
deux médiateurs et commencé à discuter
des autres sujets c'est ça l'idée c'est
que en fait comme alors
t'es pas tout à fait parce que
l'interdit syndicale c'est parce qu'elle
va tout à fait dire mais bon
parler d'une médiation et d'une pause
dans les récits de renouer le dialogue
oui il y a en fin de cortège des
violences d'ailleurs je rappelle au
passage que bien souvent ce qu'on
appelle les Black Blocs ne sont pas
forcément des ressortissants français
qui viennent un peu dépays étrangers et
que les policiers madame monsieur
répondre à des ordres c'est leur statut
ils peuvent pas le refuser donc et que
donc un policier il respecte des ordres
des ordres qui viennent d'un ministère
voilà donc
un policier il obéit et on lui donne des
ordres voilà et donc il faut quand même
reconnaître que ils font leur travail et
que pour notre part en tout cas Force
Ouvrière on condamne et les violences
des Black Blocs comme on condam
éventuellement quelques dérapages des
policiers et c'est très minimum
on a fait des propositions Olivier
Veyron a balayé de nouveau d'un revers
de main médiation ce qui fait qu'on
appelle de nouveau à une mobilisation
jeudi prochain ce qu'on souhaite nous
c'est qu'on mette de côté les 64 ans et
l'accélération de la loi Touraine et que
on regarde les questions d'emploi je
l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure
si vous augmentez l'emploi des seniors
de 10 points c'est 50 milliards quand
vous mettez 50 milliards
et c'était ça la solution
même le modem vous demande de saisir
cette main tendue de l'Inter syndicat et
de Laurent Berger même le modem est pour
la médiation Mathieu Lefebvre a répondu
très clairement on a pas besoin de
médiation pour se parler regardez
d'ailleurs on est en train de se parler
en revanche ce sur quoi en
transitionnera jamais c'est l'équilibre
de notre système de retraite et on peut
pas se contenter monsieur de dire il
faut plus de seigneurs au travail où il
faut améliorer
usure professionnelle pénibilité
conditions de travail faire une pause
dans cette réforme des retraites
remettre les choses à l'endroit pourquoi
ne pas le faire et on parle beaucoup de
la forme mais on parle pas beaucoup du
fond de ce texte qui améliore
singulièrement les conditions de travail
des employés les conditions de prise en
compte de la pénibilité personne n'en
parle les hommes 6 milliards par an
égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes c'est pas appliquée par les
entreprises que faites-vous pour que les
entreprises appliquent la loi et donc
face l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes 6 milliards par an voilà vous
avez terminé il suffit pas d'un
claquement de doigts de dire on fait
l'égalité de l'arrière entre les hommes
et les femmes ça nous fait pas comme ça
le dos rond en attendant que ça se tasse
vous jouez l'opinion
on est là pour continuer à travailler au
service des Français et d'ailleurs le
Parlement continue à fonctionner avec
des textes utiles pour les Français hier
sur le permis qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour sortir de la crise mais pour sortir
de la crise on nous n'avons pas le
monopole de la sortie de crise la sortie
de crise elle appartient aussi au
syndicat elle appartient aussi aux
organisations politiques pour définir
les voies d'amélioration du travail du
travail parlementaire ça s'appelle un
face à face il est étendu il est figé on
en sortira pas ce soir on va s'arrêter
là merci beaucoup on va suivre ce
feuilleton des retraites évidemment
quotidiennement sur SCP merci d'avoir
participé à ce débat vous restez avec
moi Salomé ça qui est dans une dizaine
de minutes elle est partie près de nos
affranchis ce soir l'appel de Léa
chamboncet a refondé de fond en comble
la police à l'image du débat qui a lieu
aux États-Unis après l'assassinat de
George Floyd le regard de Vincent Hugues
sur le nouvel épisode de chantage
nucléaire de Vladimir Poutine et puis
Bourbon Express retour ce soir avec
Stéphanie et Pierre sur la bataille en
arrière entre pro et anti-ups pour la
législative partielle mais d'abord on va
parler donc un peu de vous c'est le
messager et surtout de votre livre
paresseux inculte individualiste c'est
pour battre en brèche tous les clichés
sur la jeunesse que vous avez pris la
plume soit jeunes et toi chez Payot
c'est le titre c'est aussi un slogan 68
on voit cela dans l'invitation de Maïté
Frémont et on en parle ensemble juste
après regarder
si on vous invite Salomé saké c'est pour
nous parler de la Genèse 9 millions de
Françaises et de Français
âgés de 18 à 29 ans une génération à qui
l'on dit selon vous trop souvent soit
jeune et toi titre clin d'oeil d'un
slogan de Mai 68 pour nourrir cette
enquête de 277 pages vous avez recueilli
de nombreux témoignages de jeunes façon
pour vous de répondre à ceux qui disent
deux qu'ils sont narcissiques ou encore
paresseux clichés qui colle à la peau du
jeûne qui a souvent du mal à se faire
entendre pas seulement celui
d'aujourd'hui mais aussi celui d'hier
j'aurai le temps une minute de m'énerver
juste de m'énerver et de paraître pour
un petit merdeux un petit jeune de plus
la pagaille partout je préfère m'en
aller tout de suite si j'avais su que je
ne peux rien dire j'aurais dormi
beaucoup plus tard je vous remercie
je ne se lave-toi
Salomé saké vous avez 27 ans vous êtes
suivi sur Twitter par plus de 174 000
personnes vous êtes journaliste engagé
dites-vous mais surtout pas militante
nouveau visage médiatique le grand
public vous découvre notamment chez nous
sur LCP vous l'aurez compris protéger
les océans c'est une question de survie
vous assumez une posture générationnelle
sur des sujets comme la crise climatique
ou encore économique soit jeune et
tais-toi et votre tout premier ouvrage
et vous l'expliquez dès le début une
séquence déclenche l'écriture de ce
livre
là
je suis pas libre à cause de vous n'êtes
pas libre nous
[Musique]
le 25 mai dernier un homme d'une
soixantaine d'années actionnaire de
Total énergie insultes cette jeune
militante pour le climat qui bloque
l'entrée du groupe boomer versus jeune
indignation que vous transformez en
carburantes se sont ceux qui s'engagent
pour leur vieux écologiste vous savez
moi j'ai connu des écologistes bien
pluvieux que moi qui qui était
extrêmement militant extrêmement engagé
certains ont éclairé les générations
présentement parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de choses qui ont été faites depuis les
années 60-7080 tout le monde l'oublie y
compris en matière de tri etc et donc je
pense que la réalité est beaucoup moins
manichéenne que ce que vous affirmez là
alors une question ce soir Salomé saké
comme le disait Pierre Bourdieu la
jeunesse n'est-elle pas qu'un mot et
l'âge une donnée socialement manipulable
et il manipuler
réponse Salomé saké oui bien sûr que la
jeunesse n'est qu'un mot après elle est
quand même encadrée statistiquement
parce que c'est quand même des enjeux
différents auxquels font face les
différentes tranches d'âge donc
effectivement il faut mettre des
chiffres à un certain moment et faire
des choix moi dans mon livre j'ai choisi
de parler des 18-29 ans mais bien sûr
que c'est ouvert à toutes les
interprétations on peut lui faire un peu
dire ce qu'on veut elle pense aussi elle
pense là il faut prendre ça à faire je
parle vraiment pas d'une jeunesse mais
de déjeunesse et les sociologues font
toujours très attention à dire des
jeunesse pas une jeunesse et
effectivement à ne pas essayer de faire
dire à une un corps indéfini tout et
n'importe quoi quel est le cliché qui
vous agace le plus sur la jeunesse je
pensais beaucoup paresseuse génération Y
qui passaient 18 heures quitter le
bureau c'est vraiment les accusations en
paraissent qui reviennent beaucoup que
moi j'ai beaucoup pu entendre aussi dans
mon entourage et qui ne se retrouve pas
du tout dans les chiffres en réalité
aujourd'hui les jeunes veulent
réellement travailler veulent construire
aussi un avenir meilleur veulent
participer à notre société à la
construction aussi de notre de notre
avenir collectif simplement
effectivement peut-être qu'ils veulent
le faire différemment en tout cas ils
doivent le faire dans des conditions
socio-économiques qui sont
particulièrement difficiles un chiffre
que j'ai pas eu le temps de donner tout
à l'heure mais que je veux vraiment
donner le soir c'est que le taux
d'emploi précaire des 15-24 ans est
passé de 17,3% à 52,6 % entre 1982 et
aujourd'hui et donc en fait le marché de
l'emploi aujourd'hui est extrêmement
tendu pour les jeunes et ce sont les
premiers abonnés à des statuts qui
n'existaient tout simplement pas dans
les années 70 qui sont
l'auto-entrepreneuriat l'intérim le CDD
enfin il y a vraiment toute une
multitude de statuts qui rendent
l'entrée dans le marché sur le marché de
l'emploi extrêmement difficile vous le
montrez très bien d'ailleurs dans tout
le livre c'est vraiment dur d'avoir 20
ans en 2023 et c'est plus dur qu'avant
c'est plus dur socialement le chômage
est plus important les emplois sont plus
précaires les diplômes ne suffisent plus
à décrocher un travail et la pauvreté
est plus grande chez les jeunes est-ce
que c'est la faute des boomers
alors c'est je pense que c'est
complètement
inutile de chercher des coupables et je
le précise à de nombreuses reprises je
cherche pas à blâmer une classe d'âge au
même titre que j'aime pas qu'on
propose des clichés sur les jeunes je
voudrais pas moi divulguer des clichés
sur les plus âgés et je pense vraiment
que ça sert à rien c'est plus une idée
de comment est-ce qu'on construit la
suite de manière indéniable les ce qu'on
appelle les boomers enfin les baby
boomers la génération d'après-guerre
avec les trois paix progrès prospérité
pleine emploi et paix les quatre P les
quatre pe de l’historien Jean-François
cyrinelli effectivement ont été utilisés
pour qualifier une espèce de parenthèse
dorée on peut pas culpabiliser les gens
qui ont vécu ça et d'en avoir profité ce
qu'on essaie de dire c'est que ceux qui
nous critiquent eux n'ont pas eu souvent
à gérer les mêmes choses vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que les aînés ont
bien conscience des difficultés
de laisser un monde extrêmement
difficile pour leurs enfants vous
trouvez qu'il y a pas cette liste de
conscience là je pense que évidemment il
doit toujours y en avoir mais moi
j'entends beaucoup dans mon entourage et
surtout dans la bouche des jeunes que
j'ai interrogé et qui était si nombreux
à me mais merci d'écrire ce livre parce
que je vais pouvoir l'offrir à mes
parents l'offrir à mes grands-parents
pour qu'enfin ils comprennent pour
préciser on fait face vous avez
interrogé des jeunes à partir de votre
communauté de followers c'est ça l'idée
au tout début mais après pas du tout je
suis vraiment passée par je suis allée
directement sur le terrain dans des
endroits où j'ai pu trouver des jeunes
notamment dans des établissements
scolaires ou je suis allée interroger
des jeunes pour le complètement au
hasard où j'ai essayé de passer par
d'autres sources donc j'ai vraiment fait
l'effort d'interroger des jeunes qui ne
connaissaient pas mon travail qui
n'avait pas du tout les mêmes idées
politiques que moi il y a vraiment des
jeunes d'une gauche plutôt radicale
jusqu'à l'extrême droite en passant par
des jeunes complètement apolitiques et
au début vous leur demandiez enfin
c'était l'idée quels sont vos rêves
absolument vous avez annoncé à cette
question c'est ça oui parce qu'en fait
j'ai posé des questions extrêmement
basiques aux jeunes c'était vraiment
racontez-moi votre vie et d'ailleurs ils
étaient très nombreux voire tous ont
accepté en fait de me raconter ce qu'il
est préoccupé et donc dans les questions
il y avait à quoi vous rêvez et très
rapidement j'ai changé de question
c'était plutôt est-ce que vous rêvez
parce que j'ai constaté un certain
pessimisme très profond chez les jeunes
que j'ai retrouvé après dans les toutes
les études de statistiques sociologiques
qui sont menées où on a une augmentation
du pessimisme ou les jeunes ont des
difficultés profondes à se projeter dans
l'avenir et à s'imaginer vivre dans 10
20 30 ans dans ce monde qui est de plus
en plus sombre de plus en plus
inquiétant et qui ne leur promet rien de
vraiment
bon pour l'avenir on va parler du
dérèglement climatiques dans un instant
c'est l'une des principales angoisses
vis-à-vis de la vie Emmanuel Macron
l'avait reconnu cette phrase c'est dur
d'avoir 20 ans 2020 il la prononçait
pendant la pandémie vous trouvez qu'il a
rien compris qu'il a rien fait pour les
jeunes alors clairement il n'a pas fait
le nécessaire et ça c'est pas moi qui le
dis ce sont les différents économistes
et sociologues qui aujourd'hui sont
observateurs de ce qui se fait en termes
de politique publique pas un euro dans
les CROUS préservatifs je parle pas en
monnaie politique économique je parle
pas à mon ange donne vraiment je suis
allée interviewer des économistes des
sociologues qui trouvent que c'est
totalement insuffisant et donc oui il y
a eu un effort qui a été fait d'ailleurs
qui a un certain coût je pense au plan
un jeune une solution je pense
aujourd'hui au service national
universel qui
plutôt cher en termes de politique
publique mais
le service national universel pour moi
est vraiment un exemple de politique
inadapté de la jeunesse c'est à dire que
ça coûte deux mois qu'ils sont en train
de renoncer à la généralisation ça coûte
2 milliards d'euros et à côté de ça on a
la moitié des fils alimentaires pour
l'aide des Restos du cœur qui sont
composés de moins de 26 ans c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des jeunes qui n'ont pas à
manger aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se loger si vous allez
demander aux jeunes c'est quoi votre
problème aujourd'hui la plupart c'est la
précarité l'accès d'emploi l'accès aux
études et on leur propose une mesure
enfin qui vaut extrêmement cher service
national complètement décalé qui ne
correspond pas à la réalité donc il y a
eu des petites petites mesures comme le
repas 1 euro qui sont arrivés souvent
très tard en pleine pandémie et on a mis
huit mois à avoir vraiment des mesures
qui soient mises en place par le
gouvernement et qui sont totalement
insuffisantes dernière chose qu'il
faudrait faire tiens parce que le
constat il est implacable mais il y a
beaucoup d'idées dans le débat un RSA
jeune par exemple un revenu universel ça
vous seriez favorable vous parlez
beaucoup aussi de la jeunesse des
politisés est-ce il faudrait faire le
vote obligatoire c'est des pistes ou pas
pour vous moi la première des pistes
c'est d'écouter la jeunesse et c'est
vraiment pour ça que j'ai écrit ce livre
et c'est pour ça qu'il est vraiment à
destination aussi quoi des plus âgés
pour aider responsables politiques bien
évidemment de se dire mais en fait les
préoccupations première des jeunes c'est
ça et clairement les politiques
publiques aujourd'hui ne répondent pas à
ses préoccupations là moi je suis pas
économiste je ne suis pas une femme
politique je veux pas dire la solution
ce serait trop simple en revanche
j'essaie de donner la parole à des
spécialistes qui eux proposent des
solutions donc effectivement il y a le
RSA pour les moins de 25 ans il y a des
politiques de l'emploi il y a des
réinjections notamment d'argent dans le
système d'éducation nationale il y a
plein de propositions qui aujourd'hui en
tout cas ne sont pas écoutées mais vous
êtes quand même optimiste sur les
générations la guerre des générations
n'aura pas lieu c'est une fausse guerre
écrivez vous d'ailleurs vous reprenez la
phrase de Camille Étienne dans son
documentaire pourquoi et en fait on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir une guerre
de générations aujourd'hui c'est
indispensable que les plus âgés nous
nous écoutent et une forme d'empathie
une empathie assez forte à l'égard des
jeunes générations pour vouloir
préserver leur futur et je parle
d'urgence écologique et je donne encore
une fois la parole à des scientifiques
des personnes qui nous expliquent à quoi
va ressembler le monde dans lequel on
est en train de nous léguer aujourd'hui
et clairement ça nous rend ça nous
terrifie pour une grande partie des
jeunes et on l'a vu dans le reportage
d'ailleurs que vous avez fait tout à
l'heure donc on a besoin que les plus
âgés non seulement nous considèrent et
ne nous blâme pas quand on essaie de
s'engager mais en plus nous aide à leur
échelle et vite parce qu'on ne peut pas
attendre et on a besoin d'une
mobilisation intergénérationnelle
immédiate pour terminer est-ce que vous
pensez que les démocraties sont les
systèmes politiques les plus adaptés aux
mesures radicales qu'il faut prendre
pour le contre le réchauffement
climatique Jean-Marc Jancovici par
exemple qu'une dictature éclairée pour
planifier à 50 ans ce serait plus utile
moi je pense qu'on peut pas arriver à
faire accepter des choses massivement
sans démocratie et sans participation
citoyenne et c'est pour ça encore une
fois que j'ai écrit ce genre de
d'ouvrage c'est que j'espère que ça va
passer demain en main et qu'on va
réussir à construire collectivement et
pas une personne en haut qui imposerait
ça en tout cas et elles sont il est
passé par les mains de la rédaction de
la chaîne parlementaire soit jeune et
toi séché Payot réponse à ceux qui
critiquent la jeunesse premier bouquin
et c'est une somme extrêmement
documentée signée Salomé saké vous
restez avec moi on termine comme chaque
soir avec les parties pris de nos
affranchis vous pourrez réagir Salomé on
les accueille tout de suite
du podcast popol le grand reporter
Vincent Huger pour l'international
bonsoir à tous les deux installez-vous
on commence comme chaque soir par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir Stéphanie ce soir
bonsoir Myriam moi c'est Myriam moi
c'est Stéphanie Bourbon Express vous
emmène donc en Ariège pour un nouvel
épisode de La Guerre des Roses il y
avait dimanche au pied des Pyrénées le
premier tour d'une législative partielle
à la sortie la situation est très
différente de celle de juin dernier
cette fois la candidate Renaissance
dégringole et est éliminé au premier
tour le rassemblement national progresse
mais ne se qualifie pas résultat au
second tour ce sera donc un duel
fratricide 100% gauche d'un côté à
gauche sur la photo Bénédicte taurine la
députée sortante de la France insoumise
soutenu par toute la nupesse Parti
socialiste compris elle a fait
31,18% des voix de l'autre côté à gauche
toujours mais à droite sur la photo
Martin Frogier une candidate socialiste
mais dissidente qui a fait
26,42% des voix mais pour Bénédicte
taurine ce n'est pas une guerre des
gauches car voici ce qu'elle dit en
substance de la République pardon la
gauche c'est moi si Madame projet
portait les valeurs de la gauche elle
serait dans la nuit passe à mon sens et
ensuite elle a quand même le soutien de
Madame Tribout donc la République en
marche donc par conséquent pour moi elle
reflète quand même le centre droit donc
pour moi la seule candidat de gauche
c'est moi
alors ce duel est reflète parfaitement
les tiraillements entre les pros et les
anti-ups au parti socialistes la
direction nationale du PS a choisi son
camp elle appelle à voter pour Bénédicte
taurine la candidate vous suivez
insoumise pas pour la candidate
socialiste hier soir sur notre plateau
le patron du PS expliquait qu'il n'avait
pas le choix
cette élection est une réplique de
l'élection législative de juin et que
donc nous avons passé un accord engin et
que moi je tiens à notre signature si
demain matin j'explique que au fond je
signe des accords mais que je ne les
respecte pas qui signera encore avec moi
le PS a même carrément appelé Martin
Froget au désistement républicain les
Ariégeois n'ont pas franchement apprécié
républicain il me semble que c'était un
face aux Front National au rassemblement
national et c'est pas l'accord de la
fédération de l'Ariège puisque à 95% à
plus même les militants m'ont demandé de
repartir en campagne donc par respect
pour les électeurs qui l'a quand même
mettre au deuxième tour et puis par
respect pour les militants les
sympathisants moi je resterai candidate
et Martine Froget a des raisons
d'espérer la victoire elle a gagné 8
points à une centaine de voix par
rapport à juin 2022 dans une législative
partielle où vous le savez la
participation est toujours moindre par
rapport à l'élection initiale la
dissidente socialiste espère aussi que
le report dévoie de renaissance cell
race sa victoire alors qui de la gauche
pro-up ou de la gauche antiupes gagnera
réponse dimanche soir et on sera là
évidemment sur LCP pour suivre cette
guerre des gauches dans l'Ariège merci
Stéphanie Despierres Léa vous voulez
revenir sur les violences policières
dénoncées par bon nombre d'associations
et d'ONG vous nous dites ce soir qu'il
est urgent d'engager une réflexion
autour de notre rapport au système
répressif en effet alors vous imaginez
bien que côté politique et responsable
politique actuellement ceux qui sont aux
manettes et vous l'aurez compris qu'il
s'agit essentiellement de renforcer les
moyens les forces de l'ordre côté
société civile on voit qu'il y a des
mouvements qui émergent depuis les
années 70 et qui prône la fin de notre
système pénal bien casser peu des
battues dans les médias et au sein de
institutions politiques la question de
notre rapport au système policier et
carcéral prend de plus en plus d'ampleur
dans les milieux militants et notamment
les milieux antiracistes et féministes
ainsi est compte tenu quand même des
violences policières qui ont été mises
au grand jour à ses récemment peut-être
qu'il serait intéressant effectivement
de nous questionner à notre apport au
système pénal essayer de réflexion qui
ont entamer les Américains depuis 2020
après l'assassinat de George Floyd par
les policiers absolument grâce aux
mouvements difformes de police qui
signifie en français des financer la
police qui est née au lendemain de ce
meurtre plus de 840 millions de dollars
ont été retirés des budgets des polices
locales pour être consacré à hauteur de
160 millions des investissements afin
d'améliorer les conditions de vie dans
les quartiers les plus précaires du
social et de la prévention plutôt que de
la répression policière c'est ce que
réclame encore et toujours les
militantes et militants qui se
mobilisent contre les violences
policières mais mais le compte n'y est
pas tout à fait car malgré cette
victoire la promesse qui avait été faite
par les démocrates de mener une profonde
réforme du système policier aux
États-Unis n'a pas été tenu bien que
l'opinion publique qui soit globalement
assez favorable ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est que des réformes ont
été mises en place au niveau local avec
la mise en place notamment de
commissions citoyennes visant à
surveiller davantage les forces de
l'ordre aussi des des formations de
sorte à
éduquer et à casser les préjugés auprès
des agents et agent de police mais les
violences policières ne reculent pas
malgré tout elles ont même augmenté en
2022 le mouvement donc différentes de
police est toujours aussi actif et il
est soutenu par des personnalités
politiques de premier plan aux
États-Unis comme les lunes New York
alors Alexandria okaccio Cortes qui
milite également pour la de nombreuses
prisons je rappelle que le système de la
police aux États-Unis est très différent
d'une autre ce mouvement defend the
police des financer la police inscrit
dans un mouvement plus global absolument
on peut le relier effectivement au
mouvement plus global de
l'abolitionnisme pénal qui a pour
particularité de demander la fin des
tribunaux la fin de la police mais aussi
ah oui effectivement c'est assez radical
en quelque sorte et la fin du système
pénal dans son ensemble il se trouve que
ce mouvement est incarné en la personne
et la philosophe est extrêmement reconnu
militante extrêmement reconnu en jella
Davis et malheureusement à mon sens en
tout cas il connaît encore des échos
assez timides en France vous suivez ce
mouvement des fins the police je trouve
que l'option est intéressante je sais
pas s'il faut aller jusque là mais en
tout cas ça mérite d'être traité la
question de la prévention plutôt que de
la répression en tout cas à faire à
suivre avec deux systèmes quand même il
faut le rappeler bien distincts Vincent
je voulais dire un mot sur ce qui se
passe dans l'hémicycle avant de vous
laisser la parole au moment où les
députés s'apprêtent à voter ce soir une
résolution pour reconnaître vous le
voyez sur ces images comme génocide lol
la grande famille organisée par Moscou
en 1932 qui a tué des millions
d'ukrainien bien vous voyez d'ailleurs
l'ambassadeur du crâne en France dans
les tribunes et bien Vincent vous allez
nous parler de Vladimir Poutine ce soir
Vladimir Poutine qui agite une nouvelle
fois la menace nucléaire en annonçant le
déploiement d'armes tactiques en
Biélorussie et en d'autres circonstances
Poutine passerait aisément pour un
adepte au nom du comique de mais du
tragique de répétition samedi pour la
énième fois il a dégainé l'innusable
canular du chantage nucléaire sont
running gag favoris invoqué dès lors que
les revers essuyaient sur le front
ranime l'impératif de diversion dernière
variante en date donc le transfert
annoncé en Biélorussie d'ogives atomique
en tendant nous bien il ne s'agit pas de
traiter par le mépris les menaces du
tsar soviéto nostalgique la sagesse
commande de penser et d'agir comme si le
kite du Kremlin pouvait dans un accès de
démence déclenché l'irréparable scénario
auquel manifestement vous ne croyez pas
bien vu rien de nouveau sous les
brûlants soleil de l'Apocalypse on ne
sort pas du registre de la dissuasion
rhétorique voire incantatoire 10
chasseurs bombardiers capables de
larguer des charges nucléaires seront
stationnés chez le vassal Loukachenko
bien un entrepôt de stockage devrait
surgir de terre d'ici au 1er juillet la
belle affaire les experts consultés
fustyrus d'ailleurs doutent de la
faisabilité du projet d'autant qu'une
corde de satellite scrute le moindre
frémissement des porte flingues de Minsk
ou de Moscou de plus chacun sait que les
stratèges du Kremlin ont installé dès
2016 des missiles Iskander susceptibles
de se voir doté de tête nucléaires dans
l'enclave de Kaliningrad cette îlotus
coincé entre la Lituanie et la Pologne
au fait que ceux qui accordent du crédit
à la parole de Poutine jette un œil sur
le mémorandum de Budapest un compromis
scellé voilà près de 30 ans régissant
notamment la session à Moscou de
l'Arsenal atomique déployé en
terukrainienne autant de l'URSS et ce en
échange de cette promesse le respect de
l'intégrité territoriale de la toute
jeune Ukraine indépendante alors
pourquoi
persévère continue à brandir cette
menace nucléaire alors une hypothèse
Vladimir vladimirovic tenta sarbouté sur
le logiciel intangible que voici à
l'usure la grande et Sainte Russie
finira par l'emporter quitte à envoyer
au casse-pipe par vague successives des
centaines de milliers de ses fils
Poutine persiste à miser sur la
lassitude des alliés de Kiev et le
retournement d'opinion aux occidentales
décadentes et veulent bien entendu
minées par les effets néfastes d'une
guerre qui ne serait pas la leur doux le
recours à l'arme de la peur à cette
terreur melinariste de l'anéantissement
est-ce que vous trouvez tient que la
jeunesse est suffisamment mobilisée par
la cause des Ukrainiens qui se défendent
contre l'agresseur russe je pense que
les jeunes en tout cas ne sont pas
insensibles à ce qui se passe en Ukraine
et ils ne sont nombreux à m'en avoir
parlé moi j'ai mené cette enquête au
début de la guerre en Ukraine ils
étaient très nombreux à être inquiets là
vous avez parlé de menaces nucléaires à
prendre ou non au sérieux ce qui est
certain c'est que les jeunes entendent
cette idée que peut-être on va être au
bord d'une guerre nucléaire et ça les
inquiète profondément ça participe aux
pessimisme ambiants et sur la question
des Ukrainiens ils ont quand même tous
vu passer à un moment sur leurs réseaux
sociaux des vidéos peut-être des
contextualisées mais quand même de trop
citer comme mise en Ukraine et ils sont
vraiment pas insensibles et ils sont oui
ils sont solidaires en tout cas ceux que
j'ai rencontré était solidaire avec les
ukrainiens et et surtout ils étaient
très inquiets pour aussi ce qui allait
se passer dans le reste de l'Europe on
leur avenir conclusion alors petit papa
quand même à souligner aux tâches de ses
fantasmes l'ancien demi-sel du KGB on
vient à disposer son chinois songez que
le dernier avatar en date donc de son
chantage à l'apocalypse survient 4 jours
après la diffusion d'une déclaration
sino-rus signée à la faveur de la visite
à Moscou de l'empereur rouge si Jean
Ping la clé déclaration stipule je la
cite aucune arme nucléaire ne doit être
stationné dans un pays étranger il est
vrai que Poutine et son orchestre les
volontiers la Biélorussie au rang de
province ou de protectorat mais quand
même pas sûr que Pékin goûte vraiment
cette nouvelle embardée alors face à
zéro de montader récurrentes et pour
rendre justice à l'Ukraine agressée
l'Europe se doit de garder son
sang-froid de maintenir le cap celui du
droit et de la liberté celui du droit à
la liberté magnifique conclusion merci
merci Vincent le droit à la liberté
partout tout le temps voilà ici et
maintenant merci beaucoup les affranchis
merci Salomé saké vous revenez quand
vous voulez sois jeune et tais-toi chez
Payot c'est une somme on peut plonger on
peut picorer sur des questions d'emploi
sur les questions de dérèglement
climatique voilà le visage d'une
génération maintenant c'est le musclé
merci à vous merci Stéphanie Despierre à
demain pour un nouveau Bourbon Express
d'ici là très belle soirée documentaire
sur LCP bien sûr à demain même les mêmes
heures
[Musique]